yes but then it wants your grace
but it needn't be
none of it needs be this way in truth
renew up
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will be revealing the deleted
scenes from the first season of House of
the Dragon it's kind of exciting because
normally we would have to wait for the
bonus features from the DVDs to see what
scenes were deleted from the season
thanks to the internet and social media
we're getting a glimpse of them already
it does look like there were a few
different scenes that were deleted in
regards to viserys and Allison's wedding
in one of the new photos we can see
rhaenira Targaryen yelling at Allison
Hightower shortly after she found out
her best friend would be marrying her
father as you can see rhaenyra and
Allison are wearing the same dresses
they had on during the scene where
viserys revealed who he would marry as
we saw in that scene his daughter
raniero was not only shocked but also
heartbroken when she found this out
I intend to marry
the lady Alison Hightower
it looks like they did film a scene of
rhaenyra confronting Allison right after
that was revealed now I can only make
assumptions on what might have been said
my guess is renera let her know exactly
how she feels about her marrying her
father we have seen in the other
episodes just how much this has affected
their friendship moving forward they
went from holding hands and laying in
each other's laps to renera barely being
able to look her in the eyes
you want him to have a son I want to fly
with you and drag him back see the great
wonders across the narrow scene he's the
only cake I'm being serious
okay yes but then it wants your brace
but it needn't be
none of it needs be this way in truth
Ranier up
I find it interesting that they did film
a scene of the aftermath of viserys's
marriage announcement only the other day
I was telling my girlfriend how I wish
we would have seen what happened before
and during the wedding we saw how she
reacted in the moment when she found out
who her dad would marry then we
immediately jumped forward several years
and now renera's relationship with
Allison is already shattered I know I'm
not the only one who would have loved to
have seen what happened during some of
their other interactions in George R
Martin's novel it says Alison gave
renira a kiss and named her daughter on
the night of the wedding It also says
Rainier was one of the girls who had to
disrobe her father during the betting
ceremony now it might have actually been
a good thing they left that out although
it certainly would have made for an
interesting scene considering we now
know how renera actually felt about
their marriage now in another deleted
scene we see renera and Allison again
shortly before the wedding in this scene
it looks like renera is helping Alison
get ready it actually says raniera was
forced to help her get ready for the
wedding now I'm not sure how accurate
that is but we obviously do see her
helping her get ready in the photos
right here we have a really good shot of
Alison's wedding dress as you can see it
looks like there are dragon wings on her
shoulders as well as little Targaryen
sigils all over the front of the dress
it's actually kind of weird to think of
her as a Targaryen because like Cersei
Allison holds on to her family's name it
says raniera did ask her if this is what
she really wanted unfortunately it
doesn't say whether or not Allison gave
her an answer I know I'm not the only
one who would love to know how she
really feels although Allison was very
nervous during her first meeting with
viserys she doesn't seem that unhappy
about the marriage unless I actually
miss something it doesn't seem like
Alison wants a divorce either then again
we've only seen three episodes I'm very
interested in learning more about the
Dynamics of their relationship moving
forward we already know what viserys
rhaenyra and even Serato once but I'm
still on the fence about Alison I do
believe that renira will marry your
grace
but she must believe it is her choice to
do so
Romero is a woman
what of my son would you have me raise a
man to steal his own sister's birth
right it
now as a mother I'm sure she wants what
is best for her son but so far it
doesn't look like she's ready to stab
renira in the back although some of you
might say she already did that by
marrying her father if you think about
it she really didn't have a say in the
matter her father was shoving her in
that direction
offer him comfort
in his Chambers
you might wear one of your mother's
dresses
not to mention back then if the king
wants you for a wife I'm not sure there
would be that much you could do about it
this is also why I'm very interested in
learning how Allison actually feels
about this herself now if any of you are
wanting to know about the source of this
information I will show you an article
written by Watchers on the wall in their
new article they basically said the same
thing I've already said here they said
House of the Dragon may have just
started but we already know of its first
deleted scene although it's a mystery
whether we'll ever see it would any of
you have liked to have seen more of
Alison's reaction to her marriage to
viserys before jumping three years into
the future when any of you have liked to
have seen the wedding or at least the
wedding day you're not the only one some
of those who worked on House of the
Dragon must have agreed as the scene was
shot for the second episode all of this
was revealed when the hair stylist and
makeup artist shared a number of photos
on her Instagram of her work on Emily's
hair and look for Alison's wedding day
we should have seen this scene right
before we saw Damon and Lord Corliss
valerion AI they would go to the
stepstones but we never even glimpsed
the wedding day until now if you look at
some of the photos in this article you
will see them getting ready for the
scenes she also wrote the dress the hair
it was such a shame that it didn't make
it into the episode she also added that
it was her second favorite look she did
for Alison Hightower even Allison's
actress Emily Carey agreed even the
director of the second episode shared
the following image on his Instagram as
well it was from the day of the shoot
for this deleted scene the director said
I watched the dress get made from the
moment I landed until the moment that I
shot it the details were astonishing
hopefully the scene will be included in
the Season One Blu-Ray box set extras
because I'd love to see it even if the
producers didn't consider that it fit in
their final cut if you go to their
website you can see more photos or you
could even go to the Instagram of Emily
Carey and see the photos from her
herself let me know your thoughts down
below otherwise I will sit here all day
and Ramble On My Own how many of you
would have liked to have seen these
scenes do any of of you want to know
what Ranier said to Allison right after
the marriage announcement and do you
want to know what Allison said after
Rainier asked her if this is what she
really wanted I know I do as always I
want to thank all of you for stopping by
and watching another video I hope all of
you have a great day I will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign